all right
and we're back again with another design
review this time about visualization
and are you going to tell me about array
plot 3d
it's on the list here it is oh there it
is
my friend okay
great all right where do we start
um updated design for
updated aesthetic design for the slice
vector plots and
some of the stream plots so let's follow
on from the all these vector plot
updates we did for 12
1 so we went
to a case where we have
fixed length arrows
and then and colors indicate
um magnet density
okay this is this this is the
corresponding aesthetic update
in 3d yes we did 3d the vector plot 3d
but this is
slice we just didn't have time to do
this one two the time
i have no very strong opinion about this
except that except that shouldn't have
jumped but i don't know where i jumped
like that
um
what is the purple what what what is the
color palette here
uh dark is close to zero and increasing
toward
yellow
looks like sunset colors
yeah why is is tim here
can he speak to this stuff it's the same
palette that vector plot is using it's
but now these things got their noses
stuck in the water
that's not new one thing that we had to
update is that those
surfaces which are there to basically
provide depth cueing
they were all yellow before because we
had all blue arrows
so we couldn't they couldn't be yellow
they had to be a neutral
backdrop and it took us quite a few
iterations before we
kind of found this because they're there
to provide depth cueing
but not dominate
i understand do we have anybody from
design here
if we're going to do a bunch of these
visual things we really should ask
jeremy to join
thank you
um well okay so what's the is there any
question here i mean this looks okay
i mean this stuff is pretty hard for
humans to understand
i think you have to compare relative to
what was there in twelve one so if you
just
open uh a regular one
oh it looks much spiffier than that yeah
okay so this was the old version
hello our live stream is commenting that
many wfr functions visualization should
be incorporated in the core language
yes except it takes 10 times longer to
get them at the level of quality
necessary
for the core language we are fully aware
of this flow
the whole idea of function repository is
deliver it faster but at lower quality
yeah and it can also be much more tuned
for different groups
which we can never i mean we would need
a thousand of these functions then
to tune into all these right although we
do intend to have more visualization
functions it's just that it takes effort
to make them general enough it does
well i mean you know this is clearly
nicer
i mean it feels a little bit i don't
know i mean presumably there are
different plot themes for this
yes and what happens if i if i ask for
for example
let's take this one here i don't know
why the first example is
is a there's a center planes example
rather than a
um generic example but
whatever okay so then this one is that
okay so now if i say plot female
scientific for example
why is that more scientific
it's following the color schemes used
you know
within the scientific plots
so how did that encode magnitude
yeah i think there's some something
wrong here
it's basically not there right
i'll check that with tim
are you sure that these conical arrows
are a good idea
i think they're definitely easier to
well
they're definitely easier to to
understand
than i think the the flat ones that just
sort of
the signpost ones that just sort of
rotate magically
i think these ones can often be a little
confusing
to look at yes especially as you rotate
i just think
i mean it has some very hedgehogy type
feel this thing
all right let's see what are we are we
getting jeremy here
um okay let's keep going though right
stream plot is
um now our vector plots are really nice
okay and now the stream plots looked
really boring
and one thing that they didn't show
show was the magnitude again of the
field
so you're proposing here with stream
plots to use color coding for the
magnitude is that the idea right
yes and it would be consistent then with
vector plot and so on
is that not already uh i feel like i've
i've
done this before at least with like geo
stream plot where you can
set some options to set either the
thickness or the color or something like
that
for them to correspond to the magnitude
unless i'm misremembering
i'm not sure about the thickness um i
mean
you could always do it yes being a
stream color function
um and and this is just turning it on by
default
um there's a question on the live stream
about list vector plot 3d
so is that this would work for list
this is a list vector plot 3d isn't it
or don't i am i confused here
it's calling this vector plot 3d under
the hood right
um but what's the slice right here so
this would just be this is list back to
plot 3d correct that's
vector plot 3d yeah vector plot 3d but
you know same thing
right and so that you have you know
what's frequently an over
dense you know this is this is incorrect
i mean some bug with a scientific
whatever okay but so there's our
so these arrows
i don't know i mean i i i'm sure you've
done experiments with the size of the
of the arrowhead relative to everything
else and so on and you really need that
large an arrowhead to make this work
i mean right i mean so especially for 3d
you know we were you know trying to make
sure that we had enough to see
against having enough space that you can
sort of see through
what happens if you have grid lines face
grids
well there's face grids or can you have
grid lines in there okay what happens if
i say face grids
nothing interesting yeah and there's no
meaningful
volumetric lines here
i don't think so um
i mean they just sort of become dense
and obscure things again
part of what we learned was that um
even when doing examples for vector
plotless vector plot3d
was that the time where you could
actually see it and understand it was
when you cut it
and put them on a surface i see
as a backdrop you know it might be a
sphere or something like that
and and
that's what slice plot automates and
make slice vector plot 3d
automates and make that very easy to
achieve
so essentially only the ones that live
only the ones that live in the surface
are visualized here right
correct which is why all of them get
poked through in some way or another
right although one could imagine a
different picture
where all that's shown is the projection
on that surface of the vector
wait but what if it's pointing directly
away from this like like tension there
would be a dots the project is boring in
that case
but i mean well but you don't know which
way it's pointing if it's pointing
normal you don't know if it's pointing
out or in
it's just a dot yeah unless you put a
circle around the dot
and that's what the convention right for
flux and
that's the same thing you know if
whatever weight it points if it's an
arrow going let's say
up along the surface you don't know if
it points up
out of the surface or towards you you
don't know which
no but there's a convention like in
electrodynamics there's a convention
that you put a circle around the arrow
you have x's around the arrow and things
yeah but it's often hard
to those are those are often really hard
to like you have to look at them for a
second
and and also you know i think it the
whole point is that you can rotate
around this and so on i think it's
kind of that's true that's true you
don't want to have to put iconography in
there because
you can't rotate it there's also the
issue of i'm pretty sure
that unless you do a little bit of
slightly hacky stuff
that if you apply a texture to just
totally
you know two-dimensional object embedded
in 3d that it'll have the same texture
on both sides
right and so you won't be able to do the
you know
you won't be able to have it look
different on each side i mean there are
hacky ways you can probably get around
that but
no it's not even hacky just use face
form with two textures
oh okay never mind then okay
which is perhaps obscure but i don't
think it's hacky
yeah okay okay i thought i didn't know
you could i didn't know it had that
option
okay this is the this is the beginning
of high dimensional visualization
stephen and that's more to come
there's two functions today this is some
kind of radar plot thing is that right
exactly yes
it goes by many names popular children
have many names right
why are you calling it radial access
plot i mean it's an okay name because we
have parallel axis
i mean the fun thing is i was look i was
working on some docs this aft
earlier today and i was thinking oh
maybe it should be radial axes
um oh
wow um
and and the other thing is called radial
plot
why is it what's the axis thing word in
there look at parallel axis
also and and
has that been updated brett uh
that is from last night i've made edits
to it since then but
okay not super updated but somewhat okay
the
the examples of this this thing parallel
it also goes by the name of parallel
coordinates
so here's the thing if you have a point
in
n d you have n axes and
your point becomes a curve
and there's a whole theory geometric
theory developed by inzilberg
and others of sort of how to interpret
things
in this new geometry which is not the
classical cartesian way of looking at
things it's a new way of looking at
geometry
and embeddings
and there are things that you can see
for instance let's say that you have you
know when you
when you plot like list plot you have
you can see
clusters or points right when they're
together can you tell that from these
kinds of plots
too let's say you had a thousand lines
or something can you tell
whether it is clustering you know
so certain features you can learn to
read in this kind of plot
and some some visualization systems like
tableau
a lot of our plots they use this a lot
because this
obviously very easily you get high
dimensional data coming in from
databases and and you know
and other sources right and we aren't
doing it yet but you then generalize
with the types of axes
why are you repeating the the axis
labels
uh because they aren't necessarily the
same
i mean i think in that case they are and
they're getting
cut on the first one is different
well i'm not sure if it's the first one
it's different if it's just getting
clipped so i think oh
yeah yeah just because it's random one
yeah right but if you look at some of
the other examples
if i were to pick these where one of the
values was way different
these would be auto scale is that right
right each axis is independently auto
scaled
right
but there's a there's an aesthetic
choice if they're not too far away are
you going to try to use the same axis
sure or or when do you sort of start
because if you use the same axis you can
kind of avoid using labeling
you can minimize labeling what is the
extent
sizes those got deleted earlier today
good
um so
okay and presumably if i say here
mesh goes to all
i got dots why am i not getting dots i'm
not sure
seems like a bug
so i think we're gonna get pretty used
to reading these kinds of plots stephen
because it's like what do you do with
high dimensional data
why are the lines thinner yeah
uh decreasing is the number they're
getting thinner as the number of
curves increases so that it's easier to
detect
where things get slightly what did you
do
it's 100 oh oh it's 100 axis okay
okay that's the case you should deal
with right you need you need a way to
prune down the axis i mean
for sure the axis labels right
um okay go ahead
at some point we should take a look at
some of the notes in
radial axis plot in b um
because with
you know sort of an arbitrary number of
axes
you then have you know sort of alternate
ways of specifying
what the styles are and that sort of
thing okay so if i say plot range here
0 to 1 that will apply to which axis
down from 100.
[Laughter]
i try making it 0.5 instead of one i'm
going to get since applying it to all of
them though
yeah yeah and if you gave it a list then
it's just from left to right
or something presumably correct
so for example if i were to say here
table
you know this thing x
x point two
two and steps of point two or something
that's not even going to be the right
number of them it'll pad or something
that's entertaining
all right let's talk about the names
okay
actually sorry just one one quick
question before that though although
maybe this is for radial axis plot
you know this function here is kind of
optimized for like if you have a bunch
of things
or at least it seems like it's optimized
for when you have many data points
and maybe there's an analogous thing
with radial axis plot when you just want
to plot you know many things you know
in an equivalent way to having the thin
lines below
right i mean so what i've been
coming around to and this may affect
naming
is that while the radial and the
parallel cases
are very similar syntactically and what
the inputs are and what not
the use cases are very different
um why i mean that's a point that's a
single point
single third two dimensional point right
right but i mean
so my point in the use case being
different
is that it's very common to do a
parallel axis plot with hundreds or you
know
however you know large number of these
points
you know so you have a thousand lines or
whatever
but you don't really do that with the
radar case
well you can in our case you're looking
at
a sort of low i don't think that's
necessarily true i think we you could
look at many
points and then one of them pokes out
and then you know
the purple one pokes out yeah you can't
i agree with you brett i mean i think
that i think that it's it's
it's much it's much worse for this
purpose but i have
seen it in a bunch of places where
people do do radial axis plots with you
know
a thousand uh points right
i mean and you know my response to that
may be that
people do people misuse visualizations
all the time
i mean but you wouldn't want to stop
setting or filling then right
so so you wouldn't want the filling
in the radial access plot if you do that
you want the actual curves just
right and you wouldn't want the color
and you'd want them thinner and
that's just why i was bringing it up
because it seems like parallel axis plot
is optimized
so that for a small number of curves it
does something reasonable and then it
also kind of
scales for a larger number but the
reason christopher is the scenario that
we saw repeatedly for this radial
axis was that people
they want to describe let's say product
attributes here is a car
it has eight attributes and we want to
compare these 20 cars
because now we can look at the shapes
of the attribute plots for these cars
let's say you can see that this is a
luxury thing but it's not very
um cheap you know
and i assume you can label these things
right you can label all the different
directions
absolutely right but by the way i mean
this thing is using different colors for
every point
whereas this is using the same color for
each point but it has the possibility of
having multiple
uh point sets so in fact this structure
if i were to feed this
exact structure it will be three colors
in parallel axis plot right
uh no that would be two only in one
color
yeah you need to say list slash at that
to get three colors
oops
okay so that is not consistent there but
this
what
right i guess this is the issue that i
mean right are the questions are these
functions analogous or are they not
yes i think that's kind of
i mean and the thing is that we can
probably make them both ways with themes
it's a question of stock settings okay
they can all yeah they can both do it
and can we make them can there be themes
that are sort of that
address these two kinds of scenarios
okay but but let's talk about names for
a second i do want to make sure we cover
some of these other functions and we
should come back to these names after i
didn't know
we're going to have this at all so um i
also wonder whether these
these things should be grayed down i
think they should
no why why
because well
we just recently darkened them up
because they need to be able to stand up
against
you know a dense set of curves but look
this function has been very
underdeveloped the parallel axis one we
haven't really looked at it it's we
haven't beaten on it
at all at the same level as as
as a radial axis one all right anyway
it's a possibility i mean the radial one
obviously is using great
grade down stuff i mean the axis is
darker and the grid lines are darker
yes okay but anyway so
sorry one other one other quick thing so
right the radii access plot also at
least by default does not scale its axes
because of for example the car case
i guess um but i mean it depends
i mean by default no i mean by default
it's trying to use the same for
everything but it's possible to say
i want my third axis on you know a log
scale or something
or i want my third axis to have you know
a zero to ten range instead of zero to a
hundred
right and as soon as you do that then
they all label
is that can you do that with plot range
or something right now like you can set
the
plot range on each axis
what's the easiest way men i mean like
for example if if i had you know
if i had again with the car case i have
three parameters i have
i have cost and i have top speed right
and i have some other ones right
then obviously the ranges for cost and
top speed are very different so
so do three goes to zero ten and
what three rule
zero ten as a you know inside that
that's a sparse input yeah yeah
well actually let me go three goes zero
to 100.
so we'll see that one go practically to
zero
that's really nice and it also now knows
to uh
label all of them
right even though it's choice of what to
label was pretty crazy i'm
not sure why it picked four well it
seems wrong to me yeah it should be five
um because it should be zero in the
middle um
what happens if i now say
what if that's a negative number what
what if that number
it's going to clip at zero
i see or actually will it
um will it go negative i think it might
actually put the
negative number at the center i don't
remember off the top of my head
i guess or oh
and then it will set the range okay yes
i understand
yeah wild oh but it has a nice thick
ring for zero yeah
i mean that's correct what it's doing
there
yeah so the first axis
wait a minute is this anti-clockwise or
clockwise
clockwise
starting at the top yes okay
and i don't understand clockwise how to
comb it clockwise or minus three
oh minus three is in the middle minus
three is back on that
that's five no no that's five
two and then minus three is just in the
middle right
oh i see i see i see i see i see it
clipped
what i'm totally confused so if i said
minus
do plot range goes to minus five to five
or something
right so you had two then you had minus
three which was
inside of the zero circle
i saw it all the way in the middle i see
and then minus six was all the way to
the the middle because it was the lowest
number
yes right it's interesting okay
oh yeah these are kind of nice
okay so now i guess this has the effect
that
i guess all these have the effect if you
set the plot range you're changing the
shape
pretty significantly potentially yeah
well you can see so a lot of cases we
see that the car attributes but you can
do that with people like people's
political opinions
you know if you have um
you can compare sort of profiles i mean
you see people do this all the time
and they can get sort of a sense of a
shape
what was that i saw a bug there we go
you want to screen capture it uh can you
hit the plus button
on the
thank you
um and also in the future we'll start to
have categorical axes here
yes for an association for example no
for categorical scales no i understand
that but but if you've got
values oh yeah i see what you're saying
well well so there's two kinds of
categoricalization
one is categorical axes like this this
is your car speed your car whatever i
mean you should be able to take
i mean okay so right now if i say radial
access plot
no i mean categorical like no i realize
what you mean good better best you know
young old
and should it just assign basically
numbers to those
yes okay
that's weird not what i would have
expected what i was thinking it would do
is label the axes here
i think that's what it should do i mean
i tend to think you're right
um yeah because you want you want to be
able to have
many different associations that all
have the same shape
and if you give it a list of
associations which are non-conforming in
terms of their keys
then what it should do is you know over
generate
and show the things with with missings
you know
with something missing between those i
think that's the right thing for it to
do
that's you know how we normally deal
with things we take the union of the
keys
right okay um
oh that's a good question from somebody
there what happens if there's an around
in here let's see if you handled this
case i don't think we're supporting that
yet
okay i mean we aren't written during the
rotated
error bars yet right i understand but an
around
in this plot would work
and a parallel access plot there's no
reason conceivably yes i mean it's
probably not
also not handled yet other than you know
showing the
the mean or whatever yes um the central
value
um and potentially it's gonna look
not the best because your error bar is
going to coincide with your axis
i know but what's gonna happen it's
gonna have its serifs on the top and
bottom which helps yeah
and then good luck you know figuring out
what the
where'd that come from just sent that on
a
live stream and pointed out it has no
numbers on it
okay which i suppose is a i mean it's in
marketing plot theme
i suppose in some amusing sense it's
some
to the left winner does pie chart rotate
the same way
as radial axis plot pie chart rotates
clockwise starting at the left
okay but there we parameterize the whole
thing didn't we
yeah through sector origin
which is different from radial axis plot
which is different from polar plot and
less polar plot
right which obviously has a positive
x-axis
um and goes counter-clockwise so wait
actually
well yeah i mean i i guess
one one thing is back back a little bit
but
it seems like you know maybe we do also
need a proper way of showing
uh error bars when they're a lot when
there's lots of data because i've run
into this issue as well
when it's like oh here's you know 100
000
things to plot and show the error bars
in maybe a way where you can kind of
tell
what's going on and right now you just
sort of get a hedgehog of error bars
yeah i think that we have actually
there's a lot of things to do
to deal with uncertainty visualization
to come
you know and there's a lot of there's a
lot of visualizations that don't yet
support it for instance
yeah i mean like one example i mean i i
don't know if this is actually an
effective visualization but i've
certainly seen this is where
you you know you even just like for for
list line plot
where you basically show the mean in the
middle and then you show the
you know the upper error bound and the
lower error bound is two separate lines
um you know i i guess i don't know there
are things like this that
right i mean then that can be done with
interval markers goes to
bands or something like that oh really
okay
nice uh somebody was on a live stream
was pointing out and see if i can get
this to
paste in here a plot like this which has
some kind of glow
i don't really know what the what is
actually happening here
why does it glow
what makes that look as if it's glowing
and this one not the
layered transparency on the rings
or they might just have some sort of
blurring thing on the edges or something
apparently this is called hypno glow i
don't know we should look at it
okay um
uh okay let's see um
all right and i assume that i i think
that the polygonal
version is hey here you see a typical
thing that i was talking about
like like looking at shapes for
attributes for different
products in this case oh and by the way
they've also they've also made
uh is this something we can do can we
have an interpolation order here
um we should be able to
um i think that the interpol i mean yeah
i guess you you could have that option
but it does seem like i think that's a
much
it's in the marketing the plot theme
categories yeah
i mean we could even set it for
no um
okay arrow 3d we do we don't have an
arrow 3d
do we yet why don't we have an ro 3d
because we have arrow and an arrow just
works in 3d it works in 3d
and you i mean you can use arrowheads to
get the 3d rendering
i see okay somebody
ages ago in the live stream is asking
about topological data analysis actually
in the next few weeks there'll be a
persistent homology package that is
being uh
should be posted in the function
repository
and other people were asking about
sankey diagrams
which i know we have thought about do
not for this release but yeah
it's come up again right all right let's
go on here because i think we're going
to have to come back to some of these
things anyway
i just want to get a sense of what's
here
complex array plot why is this
something we haven't had this before
this is oh i see this is just
values this is complex valued functions
oh boy what happens i see so if i if i
take you you're telling me if i have a
random complex function here
no how does it decide what it does it's
data it's it's
no i realize it's data but i mean if i
say uh
random complex here and then i say
i don't know minus i minus one
by the way i assume a ray plot it'll
just make them red or something
or array plot uses
the
colors by like the absolute value or
something it reduces it down
because i guess if it doesn't i mean if
it just fails
okay fine if it had just failed maybe
you wouldn't need a separate function
for it but right so this is using the
same colors
as complex plot
with the arg shape with the arg coloring
but so the og here
i don't understand so the arg is the
coloring and the intensity is the
is the abs correct
so for example if i were to do an i
don't know what i can do here an
exponential or something i would get um
i don't really understand exactly why i
got that but whatever well you might
might want to get an example from the
complex plot or whatever
yes but
but basically what you're saying is if
the thing is just varying
in real in absolute value i'll just see
an intensity variation
if you use table instead stephen you
would evaluate it at not random
points but sort of along
okay there's a there's a um ah
this is a description on the live stream
about how to
oh i see you're right it's blurring plus
normal gives glow
which is obviously trivial for us to
implement but
we haven't done it it's a good idea it's
kind of cute
blurred plus normal equals glow so it
seems like it's a it's a
image compose
of a i won't actually do it of a blur
versus a
um thing all right so anyway anything to
discuss about this this seems
uncontroversial
all right i really want to see our array
plot 3d because i've been waiting
3d for for 15 years
and and you gave us you know some
guidance on colors
you know a month ago or so um but
i expect there will be more all right so
let's let's take a look at the right
plot 3d
yeah okay so
now
so this is totally the visualization of
this is totally independent of image 3d
correct there is a method that uses
effectively the same
mechanism okay right but by default it's
using
geometry instead of raster 3d so that
i mean you get better depth cueing
because it interacts with the lighting
in a you know more familiar way
i i've also found that i don't know if
this is
a bug or something i mean i found that
often image 3d is often
slower than just doing geometry for big
relatively big things wow this is really
broken this
this help system is really broken here
um what are we going to do i can go back
to the
regular as you can see there should be
examples in the right plot 3d docs
i know but they seem really lame
okay fine you should look at the 3d
cellular tones and examples here
um i'm pretty sure that's where we
pulled from
ah these examples have all been updated
to use image 3d
well so let's take a look here
that guy and now let's say array plot 3d
well that's a lot better than this
okay now let's go for something more
serious
well actually sometimes it's a little
hard to see
what's going on when it's all over
overlapped
i think that i think that having dark
is not the best no i agree i agree can
we can we make a different color here is
there
you can use color rules is the easiest
way
but just say just say color rules
goes to one goes to
you something
we'll see if it washes out entirely
in which case
uh at that scale no set lighting
um set lighting goes to neutral or sorry
lighting goes to automatic
it's pretty ghostly
in some orientations at least
i guess this is the value of the image
3d uh
the fog
right i mean if you drop a little bit
lower in
your steps yeah say like 20 or something
then you're getting the edges drawn on
it
it's still not looking beautiful i mean
no it's it's looking
it is looking beautiful but it's not
looking it's not a color you like yet
does a ray plot have numbers by default
it doesn't does it
nor should this okay
um
let's take a look boy what can we do
here
i mean i wonder what happens if we just
like the lighting error automatic might
make it all a bit
strange yeah some comments
so that's neutral lighting
look i think you know we live in modern
times let's make it a little bit
livelier than just black
okay i don't think black really helps
anything here
right right initially it was i think
like pure black almost
and it was just
now it's like when you have a black dog
you can hardly see its facial features
it's just so hard because the
contrast isn't enough i had no idea okay
what color is your current dog well it's
it's light brown
that's that's easier
um i mean do you want us to try to match
that
image 3d sort of thing no i don't think
so i mean we could
for consistency maybe but i don't think
it's great
okay i was just asking because it seemed
like we sort of managed to almost do
that
by accident um somehow this gray
actually doesn't look
bad the black looked bad but this gray
is not looking so bad
well the black before wasn't actually
black was it no no it's a dark grey
but i think this lighter gray really
doesn't look bad i like the contrast
that it's giving
yeah that's decent contrast now
maybe i'm taking my taking back i mean
we could have a
you know a blast of color but maybe this
is okay i mean the only thing is
so the the general issue with this
though is that for example you can
barely see those triangles
inside the you know what i mean like the
big faces have triangles on them
but it's a bit hard to see i mean maybe
that's just the nature of this type of
visualization
i think that's going to be the nature
yeah
um so i wonder what happens if you
lighten the edges
i don't know can we do that well
actually unfortunately try mesh style
goes to white
okay hold on let me just try something
here that might be a little dangerous
well you need to set oh
i assumed you would need to set an
opacity or something before that
is really at all useful why am i not i'm
not sure why it's not
coloring zero
but if it did we'd just see a big brick
wouldn't we right you'd see
like one white square on each face or
something where
yeah where it pokes out
who knows that's not working yeah
that looks like a bug okay now you're
saying mesh rule
sorry that's because it's being tied to
something else the set opacity function
goes to none
i have to go to another meeting in a
moment here
okay we're waiting we're waiting waiting
for a long time here
cubes exactly and across
that was fun
um
how do we make it look like minecraft is
a question we have here
um okay we need to look at this some
more and i need to but i think we were
we had can i just cover this question
here the geo region value
question what did this
so the question here is
how you know whether the color function
is a discrete set of colors or whether
it's
continu you know a continuous gradient
surely a gradient it's values i mean
this is the thing is that there are a
bunch of it's a for example if you use
like
most gis programs by default they don't
do a gradient
they bin it and like in a lot of places
people bin it
but i personally find that spinning it
is really annoying and i hate it
and well maybe because they used to have
color maps in 1982 or something
they never changed it no i think they've
been it because
they feel it's easier to match
a rough color to a bin than
trying to match it depends what you're
doing then so in other words if you're
doing it it makes it easier to compare
to the
it does definitely make it easier to
compare to the key
but the two that i mean the reason why i
don't particularly like it is because
first of all
you know very often you don't care about
comparing to the legend you just want to
look at the relative
stuff look i think the difference is
right one thing would be
if you're using colors to indicate the
forest service region versus
the you know water region or whatever
then you want
you know different colors but if you're
using it to actually plot data you
you want continuous gradient oh this is
geo region value plot not geo list plot
so i think it
you're plotting data well except you
might be
yes i agree but the gis systems might be
plotting might be wanting to use that
as a way to distinguish you know this
well no like like for example
in qgis which is the only one i've
actually ever used
uh they make a distinction even if you
are doing gradient
a gradient as opposed to categorical
data
it still bins it i mean although i i
would say
it also generally does a fair number of
bins
so i i found like for example with geo
region value plot it'll often do things
like
give you two bins or three bins which
right yeah the current approach is
it shouldn't get you know it's aiming
for about five bins
i don't think winning is a good idea by
default i just don't think it's a good
idea i think we should have an
option that determines whether it does
that but i just don't think it's a good
idea
i mean it's totally misleading
how is it totally misleading look look
this says you know i might conclude from
this that
uh i'm sorry i don't know my regions of
china so
you know that argentina and
paraguay and uh you know paraguay and
uh bolivia have the same uh have the
same
uh deposit interest rate when in fact
they're different
but yes right exactly
i mean so they right so you want to be
able to distinguish those it's what
is that right so i'm saying i think it's
more honest plotting
to allow those colors to be different
and to have some setting that makes it
you know that forces it to be bend
i think this is just misleading
i i don't see any argument to do this by
default
wrong reasons to not do it by default is
there an option to
see what it would look like with a
gradient uh go down to a color
go to the color function option setting
i don't know if
how up-to-date this notebook is but
okay so here we have
set option um
what
which one uh scroll up a little bit
should okay oh there top one
although this is a little bit of a crazy
maybe take the
it's a bit of a crazy color function but
um right so
maybe copy it up to the south america
your chance of being able to reevaluate
this
it's been changing know every day for
the past
week as we okay fine iron books i
strongly think
that that picture should have different
yellows there
yeah i mean like that's a that's a bit
of a bad picture for the big case that
one there
that's the extreme case um
anyways if we go back to the color
function section real quick
yeah um
and i mean maybe we'll probably revisit
this again in the follow-up meeting
um so we have
um so this is design wise sort of
following what we came up with for
complex plot where we have a list form
of the color function that
further informs what the you know how
the colors are treated or whatever
possibly it should be a separate option
we can discuss
um and so if you say
you know color function none i claim it
should be called color aggregation
function or something
that extra thing
that seems yeah i mean are there any
other functions that do things like this
we could imagine doing it for everything
we could imagine doing it for lots of
things that have color functions
if it's good for you know if it's good
for geo region value
then why the heck isn't it good for
other things that that way you're
telling things by colors
right
so um but anyway so we have you know
don't do
any classification or segmentation or
whatever you want to call it
um and then you get the you know sort of
continuous
gradients um in the plot and then
yeah i get it and then the next one is
you have six values and the next one is
using k means
et cetera et cetera exactly
okay fizznick on our livestream is
saying all color scaling is misleading
that's also my claim um
the um
let's see there's a question here from
ethan about attached ribbon graphics
plan what is that attached ribbon
you noticing oh yes yes yes yes yes
yes absolutely that is planned we're not
seeing it here but but yes an attached
an attached cell underneath is
absolutely
planned right um
i think we're going to have to wrap for
now here
we're going to come back to this but can
we can we see some versions of this and
can we also talk about
having that color granulation function
color aggregation function whatever it's
called
as a thing that could be applied where
wherever color function is used so to
speak
i i think so i mean i think there's some
place places where it would be
perhaps a bit weird yeah so where will
be weird
is it's all the continuous things like
plot 3d yeah
um that will look very bad right now if
we just use that
i'm not certain about that
oh because i see because you're not
you're you you're not going in
and and figuring out the contours as
well yes yes
i see what you're saying yeah right but
i mean we can make it look sharp but
it's it
yeah right that's more work but but i
understand but at least if you know that
it's an aggregation function
you can see that it's going to do
something where it's um uh
you know well okay but something like
matrix plot you could perfectly well do
this
absolutely yes or array plot or yes
or bar chart or list plot or
you know with points or you know
anything that has discrete elements is
very amenable to this
okay what is the point i'm i'm
really being bad here because i really
need to go to this next meeting but
don't look at it your docs are out of
date
what is it even roughly
a generalization of bubble chart
bubble chart list plots so the idea is
that for each point so we need this for
the spatial statistics
um but but it's a very general idea
which is that let's say that you want to
plot a bunch of attributes
for different points and it happens in
geographics a lot
let's say that you have a city with a
bunch of attributes how do you show them
you show up you're going to have little
radar plots at every point exactly
you can have little radar plots bar
charts pie charts
um that's an interesting lion plots
other shapes lots of things yeah it's an
interesting idea
all right i look forward to seeing that
next time
um all right we should wrap for right
now uh
look forward to coming back to this soon
yep
um okay good stuff all right thanks took
comments on the live stream